avec des dizaines de milliers de cas
positifs recensés chaque jour de plus en
plus de québécois doublement vacciner
contracte de lakovic 19 ces personnes
ont-elles besoin d'une dose de rappel
pas selon gouvernement les
recommandations d'experts actuellement
démontre que si vous avez reçu deux
doses d'un arn messagers de façon
moderne et que vous faites la maladie
cette maladie là vous confirme comme si
c'était une troisième de ces gens qui
ont fait l'infection et y ont eu deux
doses de vaccin sont ceux qui sont le
mieux protégé pour l'instant mais le
québec fait bande à part dans ses
recommandations le ccni le comité
consultatif national sur l'immunisation
du canada suggère plutôt le contraire
aux provinces pour ces scientifiques
contracté la coved 19 n'est pas
l'équivalent d'une dose de vaccin un
avis partagé par certains experts
québécois personnellement j'ai toujours
été contre l'idée de compter la
l'infection comme il dodge parce que je
pense que l'impact de l'infection sur la
protection est très variable les experts
sont partagés les directives sont loin
d'être claires compense les québécois
les doubles vacciner infecté devrait-il
avoir une troisième dose parce que c'est
nécessaire quand même pour qu'on puisse
s'en sortir je dis heureusement ça sert
à rien parce que on sait que justement
il contracte une certaine unité plus il
ya déjà deux doses donc je pense que la
troisième s'ils ne servir à rien chose
certaine pour toute personne souhaitant
une dose supplémentaire y avoir accès
n'est pas interdit aux contre-indiqué
surtout pour celles effectuées au début
de la pandémie il faudrait idéalement
qu'elle soit au moins à trois mois
depuis sa dernière dose est donc tout
probablement le plus que six mois là
depuis son infection initial donc c'est
sûr que les gens qui ont fait
l'infection par exemple mars 2020
pourrait considérer aller chercher une
dose de rappel sans problème deux
questions demeurent la troisième dose
sera t-elle nécessaire pour avoir droit
au passeport vaccinale et si oui le
résultat d'un test rapide de sera-t-il
accepté comme preuve de contamination
ici et me lemieux radio canada montréal